here's your papers you are no longer
David Allan Coe Hagan software developer
instead your name is booked bond
trailer' and you carve redwood barracks
okay now the people you testified
against will be looking for you you're
gonna have to lay low under the radar so
I'm going underground
you're going under underground you need
to be beneath the underground radar so
under the seismograph you see that right
there
nerd talk boy nerd talk will kill you
they're looking for a computer geek this
is a small town if you start in with the
nerd talk you may as well hang a noose
around your neck and start looking for a
ceiling beam okay okay you do not know
computers you know change salts no
battlestar movies you like football and
you like Leno got it
what about spider-man what about
spider-man well everyone likes
spider-man right no I do not like
spider-man he's a troublemaker okay no
spider-man now your neighbors are
throwing a welcome party it's a friendly
town you're going to go over and eat
their food and be normal and not talk
about super computers do you understand
me yes sir
so buck I've seen your bears they're
really cute Thanks I chopped them aren't
the stars pretty tonight sure think
about it that light must have traveled
thousands of miles to get here uh
trillions at least oh really
uh I heard that on Leno there was a
science guy on there you know a lot
about stars are you an astrologer a
strong no I am a bear cutter I used to
want to be an astrologer learn all about
the Stars
maybe travel there one day explore
strange new worlds like on Star Wars
trap trap trap trap BEC is too smart for
me
oh me too I never know any of the
Jeopardy answers
I like Sudoku though I play that all the
time on my
my new internet I mean my old internet
was broken I think I didn't have enough
Rams so I got a Mac because I think they
make a better web the Mac lip is better
than the Windows web right it has more
sites are you okay oh I'm fine
everything you said was probably right
anyhow my internet is better now plus my
new computer is high-definition I wonder
if that means I can watch spider-man on
blu-ray you like spider-man sure
everybody likes spider-man that's what I
said we can talk about spider-man
because that's normal the second movie
was my favorite it's so romantic
like the first best although I take
issue with the choice to make
spider-man's web shooters organic in
nature rather than mechanical like they
were in the original comics of course
his spider sense is extremely poorly
defined and inconsistently implemented
although admittedly that's been a
problem since the originally Ditko
comics where I really have a problem is
in the third movie where the revised
origin completely undermines the core
themes it's the worst record since the
clone saw that went poorly yes your new
name is Quentin hunker okay your new job
is shaving dog testicle I understand
you